The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: All
right, let's jump ahead here.
Let me talk a little bit about
manufacturing in general,
and the competitive challenge
for US manufacturing.
So the 1990s, manufacturing
was 30% of US economic growth.
And it had manufacturing at
two times the productivity
level of the services sector.
So manufacturing
almost invariably
has a much higher productivity
level than a services sector.
US is 80% services.
So if you really want a
high productivity growth,
manufacturing is a
way of scaling goods
and affect product quickly.
Service sector scale much more
slowly because they're more
face-to-face.
So you probably want a
significant component
of your economy in something
that scales and it introduces
productivity effectively.
And that tends to
be manufacturing.
So manufacturing is also
traditionally higher
paying jobs.
In 2001, they were 23% higher
than the services sector.
The ratio is not all
that different today.
Manufacturing is an important
part of the US economy.
It's about 12% of GDP, and it
funds 2/3 of industrial R&D.
It funds 3/4 of industrial
research and development,
and about 2/3 of overall US R&D.
And manufacturing firms account
for a greater percentage
of real GDP than all these
other kinds of sectors.
So it remains a very
significant player,
but it's also a big enabler
for the other sectors.
So manufacturing jobs--
and there's a lot of debate
as to what the multiplier is--
differs from sector to sector,
but it is the biggest job
multiplier in our economy.
In other words, a
manufacturing job
tends to create
additional employment
in the kind of value
chains that it's
connected with in the
services sector, and supplier
sector, and resource sectors.
So the US has been running
frightening trade deficits
in manufactured goods for a
significant period of time.
And it began under
President Nixon,
and has continued
to grow since then.
The most problematic
number is the trade deficit
the US has in advanced
manufacturing goods--
in other words, complex
high-value goods.
The US is running $100 billion
trade deficit in those goods.
So the theory that we'd
seed low-end production
but make it up by retaining
high-end production,
it's not working.
And manufacturing job loss
has a pretty painful history.
2.7 million jobs were lost in
that 2000 and 2003 recession--
5.8 million jobs
between 2000 and 2010,
the majority of those focused
on that 2008 recession.
In that 2000 to
2010 timetable, we
shut down about
62,000 factories net.
The US has been moving its
percentage of manufacturing
employment ever downward.
So we're at about
8% of US employment
is in the manufacturing sector.
Other countries don't do that.
So Germany employs about 20% of
its workforce in manufacturing,
Italy 19%, Japan
22%, South Korea 31%.
In other words, manufacturing
is a source of higher wages
and it's a job multiplier.
You can see some of the
potential competitive
advantages for retaining a
substantial manufacturing
sector.
So those are kind of
background points.
Let me do a couple
of pieces now.
I'll do Glenn Fong
and Linsu Kim.
So Glenn teaches at
Thunderbird in Arizona,
which is a very fine school
for international business.
And he wrote a
piece in '98 about
what was happening in
Japan in that time period.
So Japan is on a complete
take-off as a leading world
economy until the 1990
frame, and then it
misses the IT innovation
wave, as we discussed earlier.
And it starts to have to
reorganize and rethink
its innovation system.
So Glenn argues that
there are essentially
three historical stages to
Japan's competitive pattern.
So first, it was the
pursuer after the pioneer--
the US being the
innovation pioneer--
then it's a follower right
at the frontier with US,
and then it becomes a
world-class competitor.
And he argues that,
as Japan became
a world-class competitor,
it had to rethink
its more centralized
organization
of its innovations.
So the old thesis about
Japan, Glenn argues,
is that it was focused on
national industrial performance
and a corresponding competitive
balance between nations
based on national
industrial performance.
And it was set by political
economies really operating
at the national scale, but
at the governmental scale
with a strong governmental role.
But then a more pragmatic
approach has to evolve.
So MITI, which I
mentioned earlier,
was the key
organizing institution
around getting collaboration
between government
and industry, and setting
industry agendas in Japan.
In its older period, it would
set technology initiatives
that were selected by
high-level governmental leaders,
including at MITI.
And then in a more
recent period,
it's had to move towards
technology initiatives that are
really selected by industry.
In other words, at the
frontier, the ability
of government to pick
the technology menu
becomes more problematic.
You've got to get that down to
industry decision makers that
are much closer to markets and
much closer to the innovation
system itself.
And that has evolved in Japan,
that high officials just
can't keep an eye on the rapidly
evolving complex technologies.
So that's technology
initiatives.
Then there was
technology targeting.
In the old period, there was
direct government targeting
of one or two
specific technologies
that we're going to be
pursued by the government.
And the funding was at the
late development stages.
Government funding was focused
really on advanced prototyping
and engineering development.
That's where the government
support was going.
In the newer period,
Japan shifted
towards more fundamental
research funding, along
with it's applied, to put a
broader range of technology
alternatives onto the table.
As Glenn characterized
it, it moved
to a kind of shotgun approach,
not a more narrow rifle shot
approach.
And then finally,
industry targeting.
In the older period,
MITI would actually
pick winning companies.
It would decide who's
going to win, designating
specific companies for funding.
And it would attempt to
influence corporate mergers
and consolidations to
develop strong companies.
So it's intervening
at the company
stage pretty systematically
at critical areas.
In the newer period, MITI
became much more collaborative.
And it's funding a
range of companies
and a range of
collaboration models,
not attempting to target
particular surviving firms that
are winners.
So in the computing
area, for example,
MITI goes from funding three
firms over a 30-year period
to 25 firms at the
end of that period.
So it's moving
towards a system that
is less centralized
and more reflective
of the industry
leadership, and away
from an interventionist
government role.
So that's kind of interesting.
Japan gets to the
innovation frontier
through a significant
governmental role.
But when it's at the
frontier and it's truly
a world-class
competitor, it's got
to develop a much more
decentralized approach that
allows ideas to rise
up from that system.
So that may be an important
organizational model for us
to consider.
That organizational
model, of course,
is more like what the US had on.
Now, let me put Linsu
Kim into this mix too.
And his book Imitation
to Innovation
is a classic in looking
at the amazing evolution
of Korean economy.
The thing to understand
about the Korean economy
is that the country was just
totally destroyed and ruined
by the Korean War.
And every inch of
that nation was
fought over a multi-year period,
and nothing was left standing.
It's a complete tragedy,
and the population
is completely disrupted.
It's forced to move
all about the country.
Families are disrupted.
Communities and villages
are completely disrupted.
It's all thrown together,
and it's truly tragic.
And yet out of
that tragedy is one
of the most remarkable
stories of industry scale up
and growth, and growth
of the country that--
it's an amazing story.
And essentially, in
a 30-year period,
to construct an economy out
of literally nothing that's
right at the frontier,
it's pretty amazing.
So what's behind this?
So in the 1960s
period, Linsu Kim
argues that Korean
firms are on a-- what he
calls a leadership trajectory.
And the government is on a model
of what he calls forced march
industrialization.
The government is supplying
education through college.
On the demand
side, it's creating
chebols, which are somewhat
akin to the keiretsu model we
were talking about in Japan.
In other words, these are
major industry leaders.
And the difficulty in this mix,
in the government of the time,
was its corruption.
And this is--
Korea's is still in the hands of
a dictatorship with corruption
problems.
And problem with
corruption is it
creates tremendous
uncertainty in your business.
That was kind of a
difficult factor,
but nonetheless, the government
was playing a key role
in pushing these major
companies on a march
to a strong international role.
AUDIENCE: Could you
clarify what you
mean by corruption creates
tremendous business
uncertainty?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
You're not competing
with other firms based
upon your superior products
and your superior
ability to manufacture.
Suddenly, a wild card
is thrown into the mix
and you've got to cope
with the government,
and buying off the government,
and buying government support,
if you want to stay ahead.
So it creates a whole new
variable that's much less--
that can't be managed by your
business processes and systems.
So that's why when we read
the World Economic Report,
that's why corruption
was actually
one of the factors
that was considered
in the strength of your
economy because it can
be so disruptive of the ability
to have a reasonable and fair
competition system.
So the chebols, to go back to
our discussion-- that chebols
were key to building
and capturing
these large-scale industries.
Now, Korea, when creates
these major companies that
dominate industrial
sectors, they
tend to block entry by small
and medium-sized enterprises.
So Korea, at the
same time, is not
creating a system of strong,
small, and midsized firms.
It's really focused on
creating these big chebols that
can really function in
international marketplaces.
But that, in turn, can
create inefficiencies,
as well, Kim argues.
In education, Korea hit on a
model of widespread education,
and that has been--
it's a dramatic story.
The college completion
rate there is breathtaking.
And the focus is to get a very
highly educated population,
which they have achieved.
And then that highly
educated population
is able to staff ever more
sophisticated industries.
That's the model.
And it works.
The one thing they don't
do is move their colleges
into research universities,
which Kim argues is still
a part of the model that
needs to be achieved.
There's a very strong
export strategy in Korea.
Martin, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
research institutions,
do they just send
their people to study
at research institutions then?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah,
they have governmentally
supported research institutions,
and I'll get to a little more
on that in a second.
The wisdom of the US model is
that you combine the education
system with the research system.
And therefore, you create
a tremendous amount
of learning by doing.
It seems to work pretty well.
If you're just supporting
research institutions
as separate research
entities, you
miss the dynamics of that
education connection tie.
Doesn't work as smoothly.
AUDIENCE: I ask because
I think it might just
be a way for them to cut costs,
because research institutions
might be more complex.
So they focus on making a
really good college education,
then exporting people to do
research in other countries,
then they might--
it just might be something
to make it more efficient for
[INAUDIBLE].
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yeah, I think there
are certainly arguments
there, Martin.
One thing that the
Korean government did do
was it forced its big companies
into international competition.
So they've got a fairly
mercantilist model
of not allowing--
of protecting a domestic
market their companies.
But it's not that big
a domestic market.
They've got to force
their companies out
into international
competition, and they do it.
And that builds tremendous
competitive strength
in these firms.
We look around and see
the strong Korean firms.
It's a pretty remarkable story.
In terms of tech
transfer policy,
the policy was initially
largely a reverse engineering
of technologies
brought in from abroad.
But critical
capabilities are being
developed as part of this
reverse engineering effort.
R&D policy-- it's focused,
as I mentioned before,
on these government
research institutions.
The GRIs provide more of a--
rather than influencing
industry R&D as much,
it's more of a talent
base and support base--
as you were, indeed,
suggesting, Martine--
for companies.
Kim also has this very
interesting discussion
of Korean culture
here and what's
going on that
matches the evolution
of this remarkable
economic growth.
So he argues that in Korea,
this interesting blend
of an Asian Confucian
culture of family
and collective support and
a collective orientation
gets merged with a pretty high
level of-- quite high level
of Christianity and its
individualism for a very
interesting combination.
It affects strengths on
both ends-- strengths
on the collectivity side,
but also the strengths
on the individuals side.
Some of you may have
thoughts about that.
Also the Korean War
itself, as we discussed,
left the country destroyed,
and ended village culture,
but amalgamated the
population in a way that
created a certain
kind of flexibility,
as the old social and cultural
barriers were swept away.
So that it wasn't
all bad, I guess
would be Kim's conclusion.
And then because
it's a country that
has constant threat of
war with North Korea,
the universal military service
provides a huge training
opportunity for a
management class, in effect.
And since militaries,
to be effective,
has to be pretty meritocratic.
It introduces a whole
meritocracy system
into Korean society
and culture, replacing
an older village, more
class-oriented kind of culture.
There's a series
of forces here that
tend to create a certain
amount of social mobility
and elimination of historic
social classes going on here,
which is part of the
story that enables,
Kim argues, Korea to thrive.
That military service is
an interesting feature.
Our military, back in the days--
which I can remember and you
can't-- when there was a draft,
the US military was actually a
very important integrated force
in this society.
That was a very
critical step in the US
to promote racial
integration, when
you had integrated military
units at the height of threats
of warfare and combat.
It really changed a lot
of thinking in society.
So there's just an
interesting side note
there about what that kind
of social organization
can mean in a social context.
But Kim argues that
it's important in Korea.
So Korea develops, he argues,
a learning technology culture.
So the firms go from what
he calls poaching and kind
of reverse engineering, and
then to reverse engineering,
then to R&D, and then
to true innovation.
So Korea's certainly right
at the technology frontier
in a whole series of areas.
And they've moved through a
series of steps to get there.
And Kim argues that
these are steps.
And you tend to
frown on poaching
and reverse engineering,
but let me remind us
that the first textile
industry in the US
was set up in
Pawtucket, Rhode Island
by an English immigrant
named Samuel Slater.
And Samuel Slater is working in
the British textile factories.
And the British
textile factories
realized they've got a
monopoly on textile production
efficiency worldwide,
and they don't
want anybody else to have it.
So you're subjected
to a body search
to make sure you're not walking
out with plans, if you're
an employee in these factories.
And Slater's searched every
time he leaves the factory.
What his British
employers didn't realize
is that he had a
photographic memory.
So he worked with his
textile equipment,
goes to the United
States, sets up
the same stuff in
Pawtucket, Rhode Island,
and brings a textile industry.
So talk about poaching--
that's straight poaching.
So the textile industry
in the United States
is organized essentially
through the same model,
and arguably, the same
stages we went through.
When Lawrence and Lowell
are established here
in Massachusetts,
we're definitely
into technological
advances at the frontier
of textile production
at the time.
So in a way, we went
through similar stages.
R&D investment-- so there's
very heavy R&D in the industry
chebols, but the issue Kim
raises is that there's not
enough SMEs--
small and midsize enterprises--
to provide out-of-the-box ideas
in thinking in the mix, and that
that's a problem in the system.
And he argues that
needs to be changed.
But Korea, overall, has got a
very high R&D to GDP ratio--
higher than the US.
So the problems are
limited university R&D,
the need for a larger
SME entrepreneurial base.
He argues that a more
liberalized economy
away from the kind of
elite chebol control
is an important step.
But there's a lot of
lessons here from Korea--
the role of a strong
governmental leadership
in creating strong
firms, but in effect,
forcing them into
international competition.
It's Darwinian.
And the government
education programs
that facilitate very, very
strong talent base country
are clearly key.
And the government use
crisis to force its firms--
it would, in effect, force
its firms into a crisis
kind of circumstance, so
that they would really learn
how to compete and survive.
So those are all interesting
lessons from Korea.
So who's got Linsu Kim,
and who's got Glenn Fong?
AUDIENCE: I have the Kim.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: OK,
and you've got Glenn Fong.
So why don't we start
with you, Matthew?
AUDIENCE: OK.
So I think besides
[INAUDIBLE] covering
a lot of his main points I think
really interesting is Glenn
Fong, he turns this
argument on its head--
where most people think
about political structures
determining how
competitive an economy is.
But he looks at
the competitiveness
of the economy, internationally
competitive-- competitiveness
driving the imperative of
the political structure,
and how involved it becomes
as the country moves
from pursuer after the pioneer
to a follower at the frontier.
And he gives the
example of Japan.
One theme that I saw
throughout the question
is how much of that process
is a conscious decision,
or how much of it kind
of happens naturally?
Is there a certain point when
the government says, hey, we
are approaching your frontier
now, we should be hands-off?
How does that end up
happening in practice?
AUDIENCE: I think the
approach is probably
the most difficult
part of the process,
just because you have
to set up and protect--
the chebols and
systems have to be
put in place that borrowed on
these sort of cultural values.
You mentioned the strong
military service at this point.
And a lot of other things
have to come together.
And so I would peg the approach
as sort of the hardest part.
But I think once you
have your system set up
and you're looking to
compete internationally,
I think that's the point
where you have to let go.
But I think you need to
reach some sort of maturity.
And I think it's
pretty easy to say, OK,
we've copied everything that
we've been able to copy.
What's next?
And if you don't
have anything next,
it might be tough to
diversify and let things go.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So
Rasheed just to used
Glenn Fong's terms-- and correct
me if I've got this, Matthew--
but when you move from pursuer
of the pioneer to right
at the technological
frontier, that's
the moment where
you ought to think
about your organizational model.
Because to get to that
world-class leadership
on a continuing
basis may require
you to decentralize and
change your government role,
to build a more
collaborative model
and rely on a large
number of players
to be able to contribute ideas.
Would you agree, Matt?
Is that right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Well, the way that
you said it almost
implies that there's
a conscious decision
about how much the government's
going to be involved.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
I think, for Japan,
what happened was they realized
they missed the IT revolution
that was led by US companies.
And we'll read about DARPA
and the IT revolution
in a later class, but you'll
see where that comes from.
And by having an R&D
system that was pretty
focused on applied
work with industry,
as opposed to
university research,
you get very good at the
incremental advances,
but you may miss
fundamental breakthroughs.
And so I think Japan
is waking up, in 1998,
to these realities, and trying
to think about its innovation
organization to open up larger
menu of innovation practices.
That would be my guess.
But I think that's right.
AUDIENCE: And the
other thing I had was--
use this, Japan as an example--
looking at Korea, it does
seem to fit the model.
But to what extent does this
model actually generalize?
Off the the top of my head, I
think of the US space program
or something like the
Manhattan Project,
where it's very much at
the competitive frontier,
but strong government
involvement and basically
targeting technologies
did lead to major advances
in research and development.
Do we think that it--
that the model actually
works all the time?
Or is it necessarily even
the best thing to be doing?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Help out Matthew, team.
Give him a hand here.
He's got a lifeline out there.
AUDIENCE: Well, I'm
curious as to why
we, in the general
discourse of innovation,
only pay attention take
East Asian countries,
or largely pay attention
to East Asian countries.
Because you never hear about
United States and innovations
here being juxtaposed
to, say, innovations
in central or South America,
or even Eastern Europe.
And perhaps
technological advances
are not as impressive there,
or the breadth of their impact
is not as extensive.
And at the same
time, I think there
has to be innovation
occurring in other parts
of the world that are not
South Korea, Germany, China,
and Japan.
So to what extent is that
premised on that kind
of American paranoia that was
highlighted in the Hughes'
piece against East Asia?
AUDIENCE: I think
a good follow-up
is we don't have a good--
enough counter examples for you,
just because the breadth,
and the highlight,
and the attention
hasn't been put there.
And I would hope in
Central, South American
and these Eastern
European countries,
they're seeing the pervasiveness
of these different models.
And there's no way that they're
not thinking about these things
or adapting their models
to these sort of things.
AUDIENCE: I was at the
AAAS meeting last week,
and some of the people who
were coming in from Russia
were saying that they had found
that some of the advances that
were just being noticed
in North America
had been made in Russia
like a decade ago.
And they had just
never transferred
to the international
scholastic community
because they were
Russian-centric.
And I thought the that was a
really fascinating component
about knowledge transfer, as
well as knowledge sharing.
Because if our focus
is only on competing
with East Asian countries
and Germany, to what extent
are we missing opportunities
in the United States
by paying attention to
other countries that
might have interesting
innovation cycles or products
that we could learn from?
AUDIENCE: Just to add onto
that-- so I think the reason we
look into Asia a lot is
because they were economies
that weren't doing great, and
then they pretty much did a 180
in less 30 years.
And there are a lot
of factors to it.
A lot of it was having very
strong leaders coming from
periods of not doing too well--
so they were more unified--
and then having a
strong young population.
So most of the countries
that did really
well during this period or
had a age pyramid like this.
So it's a lot of young
people, very few old people.
And they were able to move
very quickly, and especially
because they have
these strong leaders.
These other countries, I
think a lot in Latin America,
they don't have these strong
leaders or these periods that
come up beforehand,
so there hasn't
been rapid growth,
innovations-- even though there
has been a lot of innovation,
especially in manufacturing
in Brazil, parts of Mexico.
So I think it's just we haven't
paid too much attention to it
because it doesn't
seem like a threat.
But these other
countries have moved
so quickly that
it does seem-- you
can see it more than a threat.
Because if you
look at Singapore,
it was a country that was
pretty much not there.
They had a very
strong leader, was
able to make quick decisions
that are very strong,
and be very strong
in saying, this
is what I believe, this is
what I think we should do,
and then going after it.
And they were able to
completely 180 their economy.
And I think we're also talking
about the role of government
in the US has committees making
decisions for innovation.
But actually, Charlie
Munger, who-- everyone
knows Warren Buffett, right?
More or less?
Charlie Munger's his
right-hand person.
And he says, in the
past, in general,
countries do better when its
one very smart, talented leader,
because they can make
these hard decisions.
And in the US, we do
have an executive,
but I think everybody
at this table
can agree that people
don't really say,
he said that-- we should do it.
So the benefit is these
are very credible leaders
that most of the
time, when they make
it that position from
a downturn period,
are very talented and skilled.
And they do make bets.
They can make these
[INAUDIBLE] say,
you know what, this
is an industry that's
going to grow very quickly.
Let's put three people.
There's like 3, 30, 40
companies that could do well,
but I think these three
are really going to win,
and we're going to put all
our eggs in this basket,
and we're going to do well.
And that's something
that's very, I guess,
I would call un-American,
because we're very much--
everybody can go about it.
We want to leave opportunity.
But these countries do
have this capability,
and they have already
shown that they
can grow so quickly, versus
as other countries, I think--
I think another thing too is
Latin America, Russia, we still
see a lot of corruption.
These other countries were
able to get rid of it.
Like Singapore, what Lee
Kuan Yew did was say,
I'm going to pay everyone
about twice as much,
but if I find out that
you're being corrupt,
you guys are pretty much done.
So I don't know if it
was a death penalty
or it was very severe
sanctions, but it was also
severe sanctions upon
them and their families.
So that's a completely
different way of going about it.
So I think just don't see
other countries as a threat,
even though they have
good capabilities.
But these countries did do
amazing things in 30, 20 years
that can't be taken lightly.
But you could also
debate that it
was because there was very
young populations, because also
Japan and South Korea had
stagnation right after.
Final point--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So, Martin,
that's a very political economy
perspective.
Going back to some of the points
that Matt was making earlier,
I think the central
Glenn Fong argument
is that that may get you a fair
distance for a period of time,
as you're getting
to the frontier.
But then when you
get to the frontier,
you better figure
out a more bottom-up,
more collaborative kind of model
if you want to keep the ideas--
if you need that
big mix of ideas
that's going to enable you to go
to a series of the next things.
That's Fong's argument.
And his point is
that Japan really
had to reorganize
its innovations away
from the political
economy kind of approach
you were describing
before to really a very
different organization,
when it reached
that moment of [INAUDIBLE]
innovation and competition.
[INAUDIBLE],, in response
to your question, in a way,
I want to go back to
what we talked about
in the first class.
For a long time, we thought
that this innovation system
stuff was the way in which
the rich countries got rich.
It was just a way to
build further wealth
in a relatively modest
number of countries
that figured out how to dominate
and lead these innovation
systems.
But then other things
started happening.
Korea comes up from
being totally destroyed.
Taiwan's somewhat similar.
Economies like India,
which is obviously
one of the poorest
in the world, is
able to start building a very
significant middle class.
And China's the latest
element in this story.
In other words, an
innovation-based growth model
can be pervasive and work
in the developing world.
Now, we've managed
to translate that
at pretty interesting
scale in parts of Asia.
You're exactly right--
we haven't translated,
with the possible
exception of Brazil,
into a pervasive model in
Latin America, for example.
One of the options for
doing a paper in this course
is to look at other national
innovation systems and dive
into them.
And I really hope of
you will pursue this.
We don't particularly focus
on this in this class,
although we could.
But the Brazil story's
absolutely fascinating,
and a remarkable story.
Obviously, they're in a fair
amount of economic trouble
from macro factors
at the moment.
But nonetheless, it's a very
promising and encouraging story
overall.
But there are others, and there
are other parts of the world
too.
AUDIENCE: So funny that
you mention Brazil,
because while we were
talking about this,
I remembered that there's major
airplane companies or airplane
manufacturers-- so
you think Boeing--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I flew up
in one this morning, Embraer.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, exactly.
And they're from Brazil.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Based in Brazil.
And they are really
important now,
and will be important
in the coming years,
because Boeing and Airbus
dominate these very large,
big airplanes-- like 787s, these
very large aircraft that only
tend to get bigger in scale.
But Embraer is important because
they focus on shorter flight
distances with smaller
aircraft, and developing out
of that market.
But I just looked, and they
were actually, in the '90s,
this public private
partnership--
so came while Brazil was looking
at shorter distance flights
and doing that a lot better.
But it does come--
sort of this pursuer
after pioneer.
And I think they're
now probably shifting
to build more aircraft--
instead of copying
smaller aircraft designs,
they're having to now
become the pioneers
and really start building
new smaller-scale aircraft,
and take that market.
And Brazil's interesting,
just because they
were allowed to do that.
And I don't know
what sort of factors
played into them being
allowed to initially start
that public private partnership
in around the '90s, when
Embraer started.
But I think now,
they're probably
going to have to shift pretty
drastically and radically
in looking to do that.
But that's a place I don't think
we've touched yet is Brazil.
AUDIENCE: I think there
was a lot of pushback
from their competitors for--
that Embraer was
getting unfair treatment
from their government, in terms
of other trade agreements--
I don't remember specifically.
But it does conflict rifts
with international relations.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So Chris,
I'm going to shift over to you,
and we're going to Linsu Kim.
AUDIENCE: So I think Bill
really gave a good background
on the article, but--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: You don't
have to say that, that's OK.
AUDIENCE: You did though.
But to go into a bit more about
the process of how Korea came
up to speed on the forefront
of the innovation frontier
at that time, they really
went through this process
of imitating what was out
there, and then from that basis,
going on to innovate,
and do their own R&D,
and create more advancements
for those products.
And this trend really supported
by those close intertwined
partnerships and
almost interdependence
between the government
and the chebols.
And the chebols still exists.
Even to this day, they're
really family-centric,
dynastic corporations.
Like the Lee family has
controlled Samsung for however
long they've been in business.
And that centralist government
support and structure
has really allowed them to enter
really high capital industries
and really get to the
front really quickly,
as we've been discussing, has
been a factor also in Japan.
So just focusing
on this right now,
we discussed how the
focus on the partnerships
between the chebol
and the government
has kind of stymied the ability
of SMEs and the smaller funds
to enter the space.
So one question that
someone had was,
how can the country
catch up the economy
and foster both aspects of
the larger corporations,
as well as the
smaller businesses?
Do they have to partition funds,
have different initiatives
or approaches for both sectors?
How do you guys
think they should
approach that kind of growth?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: It seems like
the chebols are focused
on specific industries
right now, like construction
and electronics.
So it's probably
going to be harder
to get smaller firms to get a
footing in those industries.
So in my opinion, it'd make
more sense to pick something new
and focus attention on
developing those industries,
because I don't think there's
going to be a startup that
can compete with Hyundai.
But maybe there's
something in energy or IT
that they have
room to grow more.
AUDIENCE: Or maybe even focus
SMEs on more domestic affairs--
I don't know if agriculture
or some industries in Korea
might--
you could target
them potentially.
AUDIENCE: And I
think you just need
to offer governmental support
and financial protection
probably a little bit
different than the chebols need
or don't need.
But you just have to decide
what's the scale that you're
trying to look and build at.
If you're trying to build and
serve smaller sectors that
might be underdeveloped, like
agriculture, for example,
you might just have to look a
little bit smaller than trying
to cater to one,
or two, or three
chebol companies off the bat.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Chris, you think that--
from your reading of Kim,
do you agree with him
that Korea needs to foster an
SME startup kind of community?
AUDIENCE: You mean in the
context of present day?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yeah, present day.
AUDIENCE: In present day.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Is that going
to be an enhancement to
Korea's innovation capability?
Do they really need to do this?
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: Personally, I think
their structure that really
focuses on the bigger
corporations and their impact
and their ability to
really compete globally
has been working.
So I do think that
the corporation
push has been successful.
Whether SMEs should be
supported from the government,
I think it's worth exploring.
I do think that
finding them a niche
is really important
because there's
no point or kind of
redundant for them
to try to enter industries
that the corporations have
a hold on.
AUDIENCE: I'd say it's
probably important,
just because [INAUDIBLE]
innovator's dilemma.
Usually when you're big, you
focus on a specific technology.
Like for Kodak, they invented
the first digital camera,
but because of the way their
supply chain and their current
business was, they couldn't--
they didn't want to manufacture
because it would ruin
their existing business.
So the danger of
having too big a giant,
is, in order to innovate, it
takes so much effort on them
that they won't do it.
And if your economy
is based off of that
and based on those
four giants, especially
with rapid technological
innovation,
you really don't want
to be in that position.
So having that SME structure
would be beneficial.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I kind of
want to hit on both of those.
So with the chebol versus
SME structure in Korea,
I'm wondering, are the
major, major legacy
corporations-- are
they profitable enough
and large enough to be
self-sufficient-- they don't
really need the input
from the government,
as they did decades ago?
Could the government
focus more on SMEs,
and would that be a
more strategic way
to go about things?
Or do they have a
situation in Korea--
I don't know, I haven't--
I've only been there once,
and it was only for about a
week, so I don't really know.
Do they had a situation
similar to what I think we face
in the United States, where
yes, we have legacy technologies
and sectors that are probably
self-sufficient at this point
and highly profitable,
but we're so ingrained--
the government still
gives subsidies
to fossil fuel industries,
subsidizes their R&D indeed,
and that--
although they shouldn't
necessarily need that.
It's like that, and they
have powers that they can
continue to get those funds.
So what is the
situation in Korea?
Are they ingrained and can't
really separate at this point?
AUDIENCE: From what
I know, definitely
it's still very ingrained.
A lot of the corporations have--
I don't think it's
corruption necessarily,
but close political ties
to the government in power.
So it might be difficult, I
think, to separate the two.
And going back to the
point of whether SMEs could
be on the rise in the
future, I think it's also
a cultural difference.
Because in Korean
and Asian culture,
it's often more traditional,
in that it's very prestige
obviously to go into these
very developed and longstanding
companies.
And there's not so much
an innovation drive,
like there is here.
That startup culture is
really attractive to a lot
of the young millennials.
I don't think that exists so
much, let's say, in Korea.
So whether it be a
job to go to an SME
or go to a big corporation, I
feel like that wouldn't even
be a decision.
It'd be obvious to go
to a big corporation.
So I don't know if the cultural
stigmas and the standards
have guided--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Another
cultural point here that
we're dealing with
about risk-taking,
which is a pretty key
element in the US failure--
pretty high tolerance
for failure.
All right.
Look, good summaries.
To get through this, I'm going
to push one to our next--
let me just do one chart.
Just so what recessions
look like in the US
and what's been going on
and repeated sequences
of recession, here's
the 1981 recession--
dip, rise.
And jobs come back
relatively quickly.
Then 1990, it starts
stretching it out further.
Then in 2001, the jobs recovery
is really remarkably slow.
And then the 2008,
2009 recession,
even further out on the
level of job reductions.
And a painful reality
is that you still never
recovered from
the 2001 recession
by the time the 2007, 2008,
2009 recession is on us.
So there may be an argument
that something fundamental
is going on structurally
in the economy,
when you see a chart like that.
In each successive recession,
it's less of a business cycle.
It's more structural.
And it looks like there
are deep structural causes
in these manufacturing
employment declines, when you
start seeing a chart like this.
We'll talk more
about it next week,
but here's declining
median income
for the US, which we'll talk
more about next week too.
So particularly pay
attention to men, who were--
tend to historically have played
a larger role in manufacturing
industries in the US.
So this is change in median
real earnings for men and women
from 1990 to 2013--
so an extended period
from '90 to '13.
No high school diploma, men--
median income declined in
that time period 20 points.
High school diploma or some
college, 13-point decline.
And then advanced
degrees, 21-point rise.
Bachelor's degrees,
16-point rise.
This is a society
that's going like this,
and that's what
we're dealing with.
And arguably, it's
related to this.
Let me move to Suzanne Berger.
You should get to know her,
because she's around here,
and she's really a
remarkable talent
and has been a great
teacher for me.
This is her 2005 book
called How We compete.
And her essential point is that
there are different varieties
of capitalism.
We've been talking a
lot about that today.
And the different approaches
emerged between the US
and Asian economies in
advanced technology goods
in this later part of the
1990s, early 2000s time period.
So what's going on here?
IT is a driver,
and codeable specs
tied to computer-driven
equipment
is enabling a divorce between
production and design.
So in the old time period,
in a prior time period,
Suzanne argues that
manufacturing companies,
production firms were a
lot like model airplanes.
And you all probably
don't remember the era
of plastic model airplanes.
I do.
But you'd get this
batch of plastic parts,
and they never quite fit.
You'd have to work them,
and you'd get glue all over,
and the glue would spill over,
and it would just be a mess.
And you try and clean up
the glue with a Kleenex,
and the Kleenex would
stick to the model.
And you'd put rubber bands
around it to try and get it
to lock in place, and you'd
break the damn thing trying
to get it fixed.
That's what manufacturing
used to be like, she argues.
And to manage, that you needed a
very integrated vertical system
with all parts of that system
tied and connected together
to get around the difficulty
of the production process.
But with codeable IT-based specs
and computer-driven equipment,
he moved to an era of LEGOs.
It's all computer-driven.
You're going to be
producing LEGOs,
and they are always going
to snap perfectly in place.
That's how the production
system changed,
she argued, in these two--
from these two different eras.
And the classic
example is the iPod.
Apple was able to pick a mix
of MP3 best technologies,
and they tied it to
a new software access
system for music in database
form, as you all know.
Now it's video, as well.
A classic Apple move, right?
The problem with MP3
players before Apple
was that you had to
commit a crime in order
to use the MP3 player.
You were stealing
someone's music.
And it was a criminal act.
What kind of product forced
you to commit a criminal act?
It's not a great product line.
So Apple invents an
entirely different way
of organizing the
music industry,
but it ties it to existing
MP3 player technology,
which it receives to perfect.
How is it able to do this?
It was able to do this in
a remarkably short period
of time.
It was a matter of months.
So he figures out what the
optimal MP3 player technologies
are, who is producing
them, and go to them
and enter into contracts
with all over the world--
particularly in China,
but elsewhere, as well.
And it knows that they're
going to snap together
like LEGOs in the end, because
they are using codeable specs
on computer-driven equipment.
So you can now distribute
your production model.
So Apple doesn't-- can do
this in a matter of months.
It doesn't have to go buy green
space outside Wilmington, North
Carolina, or something,
and build a new factory,
and get all the permitting,
and spend years doing this,
and raise a billion
dollars to do it.
Instead, it quickly
enters into a deal--
a series of deals with
existing producers,
but it knows that it can
bring the product back,
because it's going to
be LEGOs, and they're
going to snap into place.
Amazing, absolutely amazing.
And I was in Japan
in 2006, and--
in January.
I spent a wonderful day as
it was snowing in Kyoto,
which was complete magical.
But it was mostly back in Tokyo.
And the headline in the leading
English language newspaper
in Tokyo was "Apple sells 14
million iPods in two weeks;
where is Sony!!"
It was just a reality
that Apple had
been able to spring to
this whole new product
line in a remarkably
short period of time
by using a digital dispersed
distributed production model.
And it's pretty
irresistible, because you--
that level of time
and investments
you have to assemble
ahead of time
makes this really
quite convenient.
So lots of US firms
moved to this model,
and they're technologically
enabled by these technological
advances to do so.
Now, Suzanne also goes on to
argue, hey, other people--
and she's looking a group of
Asian countries and firms--
are not necessarily doing this.
So in Korea, Samsung continues
to control the key components.
It allows a certain amount
of assembly offshore.
In Japan, there's
a conscious effort
to keep integrated
innovation model,
and control all the
critical stages.
So the risk in
the Apple model is
that you're offshoring
your production capability,
and a certain amount of
the innovation capability's
going to follow.
That's the risk.
And to avoid that,
companies in Japan and Korea
are moving in a very different
organizational model.
Both models, she
argues, may well work.
So these are varieties of
capitalism at play here.
But the important thing
I want you to understand
is that you can now,
for the first time
historically, sever
production and design.
And it's pretty
irresistible to do so,
because you significantly
reduce your risk, and exposure,
and your investment
levels upfront.
So that's why, she
would argue, US firms
tend to pursue this model.
And we'll go to her
next book next week
and discover why the model may
not necessarily be optimal.
We'll hold that in
advance until next week.
So who's got Suzanne?
Let's go ahead then, Matthew.
AUDIENCE: So in How We
Compete, basically they
look at a whole bunch
of different companies
in many different
industries and try
to find what it is that
makes companies competitive.
So they find that there's
no single paradigm.
And one of the
key lines there is
that there's no sunset
industries, just
sunset strategies.
So really, to be
competitive, what they found
is that companies always need to
be questioning their processes,
looking for ways to innovate.
And then what I got out
of it were primarily
two different balances.
One is this idea of
intelligent offshoring, where
maybe outsourcing all
of your manufacturing
is not the best idea because
there are other costs involved
with that, and can
create innovation
gaps within your own country.
And then the other
balance being with IP,
and how do you create a
collaborative environment
where that's conducive to
growth and development, but also
protecting your IP,
so that you don't
create your own competitor?
And so I have some
questions here.
I think one of the
first things is
how do companies in
fiercely competitive sectors
actually set themselves up
to constantly be innovating?
It's a tough thing to do.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Let me
underscore the importance
of your question.
The number of companies that
are a hundred years old you
can probably
measure on one hand.
They go through disruption,
and they change, and they die.
Long-lasting, long-enduring
companies are rare.
And it's retaining this
innovation capability that's
so critical, so you're driving
at a really key question.
AUDIENCE: When you mentioned
innovative firms, firms
that keep staying at the head,
my first thought is Apple.
and I think Apple's, what,
like 30 years old now?
It hasn't even proven that
it can withstay the trend.
So I'm trying to think of
something that is actually
more than 50 years old
that has been consistently
on top of things.
AUDIENCE: I think Coke is
probably my favorite example.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Coke's
one, and IBM's another.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and then IBM.
I think IBM I know more about,
just because they developed
as sort of in f wave--
in the context of the US
was looking for answers
in the semiconductor realm.
But more importantly,
they had to deal
with the whole advent
of personal computing,
and then they shifted now
into more IT-based services.
And so they just contract
out and solve your problems.
And I think it's
like you have to be
sensitive to these big
technological disruptions,
and then ride the wave
or get out completely,
and being able to shut down
kind of large sections of--
it was previously
advantageous maybe for Kodak
to use disposable cameras, but
now we have digital cameras.
And so you have to
be able to be like,
OK, we're going to
really radically change
the course of our company
in order to sustain
and stay alive.
And that's a hard decision
to be able to make.
And so I think the resistance
to change piece is probably
differentiates your Cokes from
maybe your less long-lasting
companies.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
And next week you're
going to start to read
your textbook, which
is about the difficulty
of innovation
in complex established
legacy economic sectors.
And that's a large part
of this [INAUDIBLE]
answering your question.
AUDIENCE: The question
too is, if there's
these new capabilities and you
don't use them, somebody will.
So it's kind of like
a Pandora's box,
because I may not want to
change my whole supply chain
and get rid of a ton of
jobs for my employees
because of all the things
that happened after,
but my competitor is
probably going to do it.
And if I don't do it, then
he's going to have a lower--
he's going to lower his
costs, and he'll most likely
beat me to market.
And there's a quote from
Andrew Carnegie, where
he goes like, you should
always use the best tools,
even if it's very hard
to cheat your old tools.
Because as a titan of industry,
if you don't, somebody else
will.
AUDIENCE: And the other
thing I liked from Hayes
I think about--
I know it goes a little bit
into next week's readings here,
but to what extent do you think
that design and manufacturing
can actually be separated?
I know here at MIT, in
the mechanical engineering
department, there's still
a big emphasis on taking
the manufacturing classes, in
terms of just understanding
when you're designing,
what is feasible,
what is possible to manufacture.
Maybe 3D printing, it's a
little bit more separate.
You're basically
saying can be made.
But there's a lot of
know-how embodied in having
the manufacturing there too.
I don't fully think
that they can be--
or it's wise to
fully separate them.
I want to see if people also
have some more thoughts there.
AUDIENCE: I was going to say
that maybe the separation is
just a figment of
our imaginations,
because I know that
when Suzanne Berger was
on the panel in
bootcamp course--
I think it was Suzanne who
said that the people who--
the designers for Apple spend
most of their time not here.
They spend their time in
the offshore manufacturing.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Shenzhen, in particular.
AUDIENCE: Makes sense.
AUDIENCE: So they're
not really separate,
although they're quote,
unquote "separate."
AUDIENCE: I think also
objective is important.
And if you're
trying to separate,
what are you trying to
separate in order to do--
if you're trying to separate
in order to cut costs,
you'll find a way, because
it'll be more advantageous
for you to send your
manufacturing section over,
if you're Apple.
But even if you do
that, you're going
to have to send your designers
in order to do the next thing
and really consider how
am I going to manufacture
this thing that I've designed.
And in order to do that,
you can't separate them.
So the mechanical engineering
department, I think,
is probably pretty
smart by training--
when training all mechanical
engineers who are then
going to go up design
and manufacture,
even though you might
specialize in one or the other,
you need to have a strong
basis and a foundation of both,
and understandable
are critical in order
to do anything that's probably
long-lasting or meaningful,
and I guess quote,
unquote "innovative."
AUDIENCE: When we talk about
design, what do we mean?
Do we mean the designer
of an industrial system?
Do we mean the designer of
an industrial appliance?
Do we mean the
designer of hardware?
designer of software?
What components of
design are we concerned
about, and in what ways is this
relevant in the conversation
we're having right now
about integrative innovation
processes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I'm
viewing it, when we see--
we're comparing the
design and manufacturing,
so I wouldn't think of
it so much as software.
Primarily hardware,
where the design
may be having a 3D model or
a layout of my circuit board
that I'm going to
send to a manufacturer
on the other side of the
world, who will actually
make those components, put them
together, and send them back
to me.
That's at least
what I [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I guess I raise that concern
because, as a designer myself--
I think of myself as
a design researcher,
because I think about
the ways in which you
can take systems engineering
approaches to social issues.
And there's a big
debate right now
in the design community
about what design even is.
There's this big debate
about design thinking
and versus the design cycle,
and who gets to create it.
And there's even more of
a debate about the nuances
and exerting the power
in creating something.
All of these hardware choices
are political choices,
and they have impacts on
both the user and the society
in which they're implemented.
So that's why I think it's
important to really consider,
when both the author and we
talk about design, what kind
of design we're talking about,
and we view it not necessarily
as a neutral and apolitical
action, but very much
as a reflection of what
that corporation values
and what kind of values they
want to promote in a society.
When I look at this laptop, I
don't think, this is beautiful,
this is elegant,
this is functional.
I think, this is how this
company wants the world
to look like, and this is
their long-lasting and material
vision for what the world could
look like for the long run.
AUDIENCE: Alternatively, I
think a lot of design thinking
actually is for companies
that, while we're
looking at what they--
what we think their vision
is [INAUDIBLE] when we
look at, say, a Macbook,
I think a lot of
them are looking to,
and most designers
at Apple would say,
in their design process,
they're looking at the users
and seeing what the
users actually want.
[INAUDIBLE] there's a
lot of looking both ways.
AUDIENCE: From a
capitalist perspective,
the way I would
look at it is, OK,
what are the
manufacturing abilities?
How much does it cost me?
How long is it going to take?
What are going to be the issues?
Don't make it complicated.
Simplify it, simplify
it, simplify it,
because in execution, it's
going to be way more complex,
and I'm not trying
to deal with that.
And then, OK, I'll make it.
Make sure it's slightly
different than my competitors.
Make sure it follows
the values of my company
in a certain amount of way.
And then when I
market it, you think
it's something more
than it actually
is because then you'll buy it,
because it's worth the value.
AUDIENCE: I think maybe
American Apparel and--
they hinted at American
Apparel, Lucky Brand Jeans,
and some other companies
that are very heavy--
or their models are
particularly because they're
based in the US.
And even though it might be
less expensive to like build
and manufacture your jeans or
your t-shirts, for example,
outside of Los Angeles,
you lose other factors,
which is being able to say made
in the USA, blah, blah, blah.
But also you gain production
speak and all of these things
that Martin was talking
about from coupling
these design and the
manufacturing processes
and leaving them here.
But at the end of
the day, I think
you do a cost benefit
analysis, kind
of like Martin said,
and then just make sure
that your company values
is in line with the product
and how you want people to
interface with the world
through your product.
AUDIENCE: But then
going off that, I'm
curious how much
of an advantages
that you get from
producing in the US can--
or whatever their gimmick is--
how long those will last.
Like American Apparel just
closed all their stores.
So does that mean that that
approach isn't sustainable
and that they should have taken
another look at outsourcing?
There are other factors
contributing to it,
but is that--
do these companies have
to pick what society
will want as their
special sauce,
and hope that it
lasts long enough,
or are they eventually
going to need to think
about these alternatives?
AUDIENCE: They definitely should
consider the alternatives,
but when--
at least with American
Apparel, like you were saying,
there's probably
a ton of factors.
And I think just to
answer that question,
we just need more data.
So we need to somehow control
for the type of industry,
the time period, the location,
et cetera, et cetera.
And then you could compare.
Based on the information
that we have, the question--
we just don't have the numbers
to back up either side.
AUDIENCE: Or another example--
I think that this was
written before Zara
came under fire for a bunch of
basically human rights issues--
outsourcing--
AUDIENCE: But I'd look into--
did that affect sales?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Or do you
want to lay out the Zara model
for us, Lily?
AUDIENCE: Oh, gosh.
AUDIENCE: Do you know it?
AUDIENCE: No, I'm
afraid I can't--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I
can summarize it for you.
AUDIENCE: --articulate it well.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Or
Martin if you know it.
AUDIENCE: If you know
it better [INAUDIBLE]..
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
I don't know.
We'll find out.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: You do it, and
then I'll appendix anything--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Please do.
It's an example that
Suzanne Berger uses.
And the point about Zara
is that, by locating
its production facilities it's
very close to its markets,
it's able to move production
to its sale system
in a very, very
short period of time.
So by tracking fashion
markets and what
appears to be
moving and selling,
it's able to shift its
production system quickly
onto new styles that
seem to be emerging.
Whereas if you shipping
that style across, say,
8,000 miles of ocean
in a container ship
that's moving at 8 and 1/2
knots, you're not in the game.
So Zara has figured
out how to keep
that relationship between
production facility, market,
and sales facility very
tight, and therefore, be
able to serve emerging markets.
Fashion is somewhat
different than other areas,
but the point, I
think, is still there.
But serve emerging
markets very quickly--
so rising to your
market opportunities
in very short periods of time.
How's that, Martin?
AUDIENCE: Pretty
much what they do
is they go into the Fashion
Week, and they're like,
oh, this is a really
expensive thing.
What we're going to do
is we're going to find
a very cheap way of doing it.
They have it on the market
by two weeks pretty much.
They like rapidly design and
they go for a low price point,
and then they'll put
it into the market,
and then people will buy it.
You're not buying for value.
You're buying because
this is trendy,
and I don't want to spend much.
And that's kind of their
value prop right now.
because they're usually
slightly more than H&M,
but it's just that
right model for I
want to buy a good
amount, and I don't
want to look like I'm
from 10 years ago.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Does
that sound right, Lily?
OK.
AUDIENCE: But yeah, I would
have to look at the data of how
their sales reflected.
Because I think
some people do care,
or they might act
like they care,
but probably when they
vote with their dollar--
because there's Zara
and there's H&M,
but there's not too
much of a difference.
And I'm pretty sure
they different products.
So somebody might be
like, I really like
this sweater from Zara, so
I'll definitely go that way.
I would debate that there's a
very small percentage that'll
be like, I'm totally never going
to buy from the store again--
or I'm totally not going
to buy from this store
again, and then not
go back to buying
from like two weeks later.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So I'm
going to bring us back to Mac,
since we've now gone off
to into the fashion world--
back to some more fundamental.
Do you have some
closing points you
want to make on Suzanne's book?
What do you think
is really key in it?
AUDIENCE: I think one real
key point that maybe we
didn't get as much to
talk on is that maybe we
have, as Americans, this
idea of a birthright to being
at the forefront of
innovation, and really
pointing out that no one
who's completed and sitting
on their laurels will
stay in that position.
I think there's a good
contrast between her ideas
on outsourcing versus Berger's.
Something to think about.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Good.
Good point, Matthew.
All right, that brings us
to our closing reading.
This is one of MIT's great
provosts, Joel Moses,
who was deeply
involved in the early
and, indeed, later stages
of the computing revolution.
So this is a young Joel
at project MAC at MIT,
which is MIT's
implementation engine
for a lot of the early
computing advances.
So Joel steps back and
writes this fun piece, which
I wanted to throw
in here at the end,
to pick up our determinism
theme one more time.
We've been talking about
different kinds of innovation
systems and how
different countries have
varieties of capitalism
and varieties
of innovation systems.
And Joel takes us back
a step and gives us more
of a 10,000-foot kind
of look, which I was--
I've always been intrigued with.
He argues that there are three
fundamentally different design
methodologies.
So this is a design methodology
in a societal sense,
rather than engineering design,
that Matthew was leading us
through earlier.
And he argues that,
historically, the US
has used what he calls
a tree and branch
organizational
attempt, which creates
very hierarchical firms.
And he argues that this
very hierarchical system--
and you can picture with the
organization chart looks--
it's like a tree, top
management all the way down
through many different
hierarchies of levels--
that that fits a mass
production company.
This is the kind of economy
that was compelled coming out
of the Industrial Revolution.
And it's organized
for manufacturing
at a national scale for
national markets, where
a lot of vertical
integration is required.
So think about the big
three US car companies.
Now, then he makes an
interesting additional point,
which is this, by the way,
fits an Aristotelian hierarchy
of ordered knowledge.
This is the way in which Western
thought organizes science.
That's what Aristotle
is doing, he's
creating these tree
and branch systems.
Surprise, it shows up in
industrial organization
in the West.
But he argues that the
tree and branch hierarchy
means tremendous inflexibility
and great difficulty
in managing change,
because you've
got to bring all those
different systems, all
those different levels in the
line in order to pursue change.
So the second design
methodology is around what
he calls a layered system.
And he argues that Japan's
incredible success of the '70s
and '80s is not just the
different industrial model,
a quality production model.
It's deeper than that.
There's a whole
social organization
set of issues that's
coming with it.
And [INAUDIBLE],, you
were driving towards some
of these points, I think.
So in Japan's system, there
are separate layered levels,
and you tend to move
through your career
with your age cohort.
And as a group, you move
from level to level.
And there's obviously
several levels here.
It's much less tree and
branch hierarchical.
It is pretty flat
within that age cohort.
And you tend to know that you're
going to move with your level
into successive position.
So it forces a significant
amount of consensus.
So Joel's interesting comparison
is this is Plato's Republic--
the philosopher king, the
guardians, the citizens--
those are kind of layers.
So not an Aristotelian,
but a Platonic model.
And then he says
there's a third.
And this is the network model
that the US nurtured coming out
of the IT revolution, which
is much flatter, much less
hierarchical.
Not even layered--
it's pretty flat.
And it's driven by the
collaborative group innovation
systems that are required
for the development of the IT
sector--
that a rigid tree
and branch hierarchy
is just not going to work
in that IT world, which
requires a tremendous
amount of almost
democratization of workforce.
So back, Martin, to
your Andy Grove analogy,
when the leaders of Intel--
when Bob Noyce, and Grove, and
Gordon Moore were setting up
Intel, there are no offices.
Everybody's got a
cubicle, including
Noyce, and Moore, and Grove.
The network model, Joel
argues, is actually
much faster, and
much more flexible,
and much more subject to change
than even the layered model
that Japan brings about.
And so you start
thinking here, gee, it's
no wonder the US
auto industry got
rolled when it came up
against Japan's layered model.
And then you start thinking,
oh, no wonder Japan
missed the IT revolution,
if the organizational model
required this network.
Now, look, these are
highly speculative.
We'll never prove these.
They're really only for
discussion purposes.
All of us know that are more
complex stories behind it.
But I think there is an
idea about the relationship
between social
organization and the kind
of industrial developments that
your society is going through,
and the kind of organizational
models that those compel.
Joel's great complaint
is that engineering
lacks the models
to be able to grasp
these different
organizational structures,
that you can't really fit
that within a traditional kind
of engineering analysis, and
that engineering, therefore,
needs to rethink this.
That's part of the
reason why he's
a major leader of MIT's
Engineering Systems
Division, which, of course,
has now been closed.
But that's part of what Joel
and some of his colleagues
are trying to do, when
they set up BSD at MIT.
I just want to close out
by saying that there's
another thing that
we'll need to consider,
as we move into
next week's class--
that the whole
nature of competition
is changing in manufacturing,
that it's no longer
a world of manufacturing
goods, it's
a world of
manufactured goods that
are fused with IT technologies
that, in turn, are
service delivery models.
So there's a whole fusion of
services and manufacturing
going on that makes some of
the stories we've been talking
about today more complicated.
In past decades, the
story was quality.
Now, there's a whole
level of customization,
and speed, and
customer responsiveness
that we have to
think about, as well.
And your ability to
get on top of those,
as well as on
quality, becomes key.
It's not simply the
best technology,
but it's the best technology
plus the best business models
and delivery models that
have to be thought about.
There used to be traded
goods, traded product.
Now, there's traded all
kinds of knowledge management
and services that are tied
to these products that
becomes critical factors
in your ability to compete.
In the past, it was the
workforce skills side.
Now, it's much more continuous
learning in your workforce.
Then it was low cost of capital.
Now, it's efficiency in
all the financial services
stages that you've got to
get through the hurdles of,
not just the initial
capital cost.
And there's a whole evolution
of intangible capital, as well.
So there's a whole
new set of factors
that's coming into the
manufacturing world, that we've
only started to glimpse
from today's discussion.
But let's go back to Joel
and his three models.
Chris, it's all yours.
AUDIENCE: So to
summarize, Joel is
presenting these three models--
the hierarchical
decomposition model,
where it's the branch tree
structure, the network design
model, and then the
layered design model.
And then he basically goes on
to outline a bunch of examples
where you could present--
or sorry, apply
different methodologies
into analyzing various systems.
So he goes through a
philosophy example,
he goes through manufacturing,
even more science-based--
so like the models of
the human mind and body.
And one of them I found
particularly interesting
was where he brought
up culture, and how
preconceptions of how
engineering and manufacturing
is viewed here
versus, let's say,
Germany or Japan has
really impacted the way
these countries have
responded towards shifts
in manufacturing, and how that
industry develops-- and also
how cooperation in
Japanese culture
has really allowed
the precipitous rise
of their industry and
manufacturing capabilities,
and how that shaped and kind
of forced American firms
to adopt a similar structure
or methodology in order
to compete.
Interestingly enough,
a lot of the examples
were not really
engineering-based,
even though he started from the
hierarchical model, which is
seen very often in engineering.
And I thought that was
really interesting.
And we can definitely go
into some of the examples
more, if anyone has a
particular one to go into.
But to start off the discussion.
I thought this question
was really interesting.
How does a country shift
from a tree structure--
so the hierarchy one--
to a more layered or
network structure,
once it's already
been established?
So if there's any thoughts,
feel free to throw them out.
AUDIENCE: So I
took a class called
structural organizations,
and it talks about--
so it's not like there's
a right or wrong answer.
It just really depends
what you're trying to do.
So in general, it's
more networked,
it means you want to
make better decisions.
But the drawback is it'll
take a much longer time.
Hierarchical, you might
not make great decisions,
but you'll make
them very quickly.
And as long as people
respect the person who's
making the decision, it turns
out to be pretty much OK.
In terms of a company, I
think it really does depend,
because I think the
network structure works
great for like a
Facebook or something
with internet base, where you're
really competing for ideas,
you're trying to come
up with the best ideas.
Things move quickly, so you
want to iterate quickly.
Versus, I think, if
it was manufacturing,
I wouldn't want that as much.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Chris, did you agree
with Joel's presentation here?
Do these models
make sense to you?
[INAUDIBLE] got an interesting
story out here or--
what do you think?
AUDIENCE: I thought
it was interesting
how he presented three
frameworks for looking
at different firms,
and then went
about applying that model
to different situations,
companies, industries.
I thought that was interesting.
Again, just like some of
you, I had a little bit
of trouble distinguishing
between some of them
as I was reading it.
So perhaps going into
more about defining
the differences between
the different models,
and also maybe even
trying to generalize which
model would be applicable to--
what characteristics would be
most amenable to these models,
that could be an
interesting additional step.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: All right,
I think on that good note,
we'll end a few minutes early.